what's going on everyone alex was here
ceo of joomlas prestige labs
and alan and a number of other portfolio
companies that we have we did 120 plus
million
last four years and i have nothing to
sell you so what i want to do is show
you some of the
the lessons that we have learned along
the way so uh volatility and risk so i
had a conversation
with um somebody on my team and it was
such a good conversation i wish i had
recorded it
and so this is going to be my attempt to
break this down for you
so this is if you are an entrepreneur
and you have a sales team
you can send this to your sales team if
you are kind of still in the selling
mode this will apply to you
and if you're an employee and you're
looking at making more money and you
want to become wealthy
this will also apply to you too all
right so the employee question came to
me
requested like a 15 minute time which i
knew it was something important because
it doesn't happen very often
and so i was i was kind of looking
forward i was like hey what's up man and
what was interesting in the first
you know four to five minutes of the
call you know the person was just like i
just really want to pick your brain
on like the direction of my life and i
was like well that's a really big
amorphous topic like
what problem are we solving right which
is always if you ever talk to me it's
usually like what problem are we solving
right because then we can start tackling
it
and i don't think they knew what the
problem that they were solving was
because what it was is in reality
they had family members who were saying
hey you you shouldn't you shouldn't be
in this job you need something that's
more secure
all right and so as i dug deeper into
this conversation there were so many
nuggets that came out of it that i think
i've wrote them all down on on a list
and i'm going to try and hit as many as
i can all right
and so the first thing was this person
in particular is on our sales team we
have a lot of
you know 20 plus sales people and they
they uh their family said you should get
out of sales
you need something that is less risky
all right and so the first thing i asked
was
do these people who are giving you this
advice make more money than you and he
said
no and i was like rule number one do not
listen to people poorer than you about
advice on money so for everyone who has
family or friends
or parents who make less money than you
or make the same amount of money than
you at a
at an older age uh don't listen to them
all right listen to people who make far
far far more money
i don't even think you should listen to
millionaires listen to billionaires i
think that's great advice from brian
cardone
listen to billionaires so number one
number two
they had a misunderstanding of
volatility and risk all right this is a
classic
poor person thing all right so i'm going
to break this down for you
with an example let's say i own an
insurance company
okay and i know statistically
that every nine years there's going to
be a super catastrophe there's gonna be
a hurricane
katrina hurricane maria something that's
gonna destroy everything and i'm gonna
lose
a butt load okay now
that means that one out of nine years
i'm gonna get destroyed but the other
eight years i'm probably gonna make a
lot of money
right right so the question is
is my insurance business risky
the answer is no i'm going to make the
assumptions that i have a sound business
model and
margins and all that stuff but the
reality is that my insurance business is
not
risky it is volatile those are not the
same things
all right and so if you if you flatten
out the curve over the nine years and
look at the growth that's going to occur
in my business
based on those metrics i will be far
better off than something that might be
less volatile less up and down
but not grow as quickly alright sales
is an example of a highly volatile
profession
that still is low risk and let me
explain why
who do you think is the most secure in
the company
somebody who generates revenue or
someone who costs overhead
someone who generates revenue so sales
people are by definition people who
generate revenue
which means they are the lowest risk in
a company
now for them they may have more
volatility from paycheck to paycheck
but in general people in sales generate
make more money than people who are not
in sales all right and if you're good at
sales even more so
which this individual is right and so
with the concept of volatility versus
risk
i said what you should do if you want to
decrease the volatility in your life and
get the upside
benefit of your position is you need to
decrease
your expenses to your salary all right
so his salary and i said now
your salary is what you need to assume
your is all you're going to make now i'm
not saying live on your salary
i'm saying you should be saving off of
your salary
now think about this let's say this
individual is living as it has a salary
of let's say 40
000 a year all right now if i can get
them to live on 25k
right a year then that delta can be
invested
in the s p 500 and within 20 years
they're top 1 percent
crazy i know and if you split where you
live with other people
and you really try and live down you can
do that faster right but the reality is
that this isn't all the person's going
to make
but you should plan like it is because
then what happens is all of this
becomes gravy and even if you have a bad
month which
there's no sales person in our company
that would not that would not make any
sales it does it doesn't even make sense
right
but even if you had a bad month they
still this person would still feel like
they're making progress towards their
wealth freedom and independence goals
all right but the reality is that they
would probably make you know
another 100k per year on top of that but
now they've set up their lifestyle such
that
their expense income ratio is so
favorable
that that they can save so much of their
money they get to their goal faster
which is the next point which is
wealth and i've said this before and i
will say it again is not a number
and this is one of the things that i had
to tease out in this conversation
wealth is a ratio it's a ratio between
how much you spend
versus how much you make it's inflow
versus outflow
not i need to make x to be free now if
you want to have a crazy lifestyle i
have another video
about about what living like the ultra
wealthy is but the reality is
it's a not that fun not definitely not
fulfilling
and i'll tell you what is way more
fulfilling having the freedom and the
peace of mind which is actually what
people want
knowing that you're going to be set up
for life and the way to do that is to
have a strong
income to expense ratio and so this
individual if he's making 140 000
and he lives on 25 he's making nine
times more or whatever the math is there
whatever
six times six times more he's making six
times more
than he's spending that's a great income
to expense ratio
his wealth is going to build very very
quickly right and with that
that extra money will more than cover
his 25 000
a year right like the 140 that or sorry
the one
115 that he's saving in this example
right every year in pure cash
he's already saving four and a half
years of income every year
now let alone the fact that if he's just
gaining at 10
right s p is nine but like just for math
sake let's just say 10
that he's he's going to be generating
himself
compounding growth with which means that
in two years
two years he'll be at 230 right
he would technically be able to retire
on his current
income think about that right now if you
want to if you want to spend more
then fine but literally there's a
24-month way of of saving your way to
wealth
right now would i want to retire in 230
000 no but if you worked for a decade
by the end of that period of time you'd
have two you know two point something
right and at that point
then he could he could he can totally
just retire and not only that
if he keeps his expense ratio at 25 000
maybe even bumps himself to 40 or 50 000
which for most people is is a really
comfortable living you know it's like
you're not doing anything crazy
right and if you do it that way life
will be better
now the next point that uh that that
came up was he was like okay well i've
got i've got some debt um so what should
i do he's like so i've got student loan
debt i've got
credit card debt that's that's about i
can't remember i think it was 20 grand
right between both of those and i was
like okay your student loans
have super super super low interest so
let's not worry about those
let's worry about your credit card
because the credit card has 16
compounding and so you think about that
it's like a negative investment
right you've got something that's
compounding against you versus something
that's compounding for you
so the way to guarantee a 16 compounding
rate of return is to d
is to take away the drags that are at
negative 16
all right so if you're in this situation
the first thing you do is you pay off
your credit card debt
all right number one after that you're
going to have your your student loans
and then your investments the reality is
the student loans the interest because
with the government's setting them you
know have set them up it's it's
basically just
it's the cost of you learning this
however long ago i think it's horribly
uh unethical that they they do student
loans i think i'm so
wildly against student loans in general
in what world would someone ever give an
18 year old
access to 200 000 who has no skills
whatsoever
to then get something that has no return
more than what their current earning
potential is it makes no sense
and if you if you if you can't even
bankrupt your way out of it it is purely
a scheme by banks to make more money
purely it makes you a slave to the bank
for the rest of your life
but there's no interest on it and so i'm
not going to think about that for right
now all right so credit card loans
first and then you stack into
investments now me personally i just
don't like having any debt and so if you
want to it's a personal choice it
doesn't even make mathematical sense it
makes emotional sense
um you can pay off the student loans and
then everything else gets plowed into
the s p 500 the reason i say that is
because warren buffett
the advice that he's given the people
who are managing his will
is that he just wants everything put in
the s p 500
smartest investor of of all time that's
what he's doing so i think it is
worthwhile advice and very easy to
follow
all right next one and you do this every
month it's called dollar cost averaging
so that even when it goes down and goes
up
you're going to participate at all times
so when it's overpriced you're still
buying
and when it's underpriced you're still
buying don't try and time it
i have another video about trying to
time the market you're going to lose so
just
dollar cost average in and then get rid
of any of the anxiety around
getting a good deal all right next one
so he's like okay
i want to make uh you know i want to
know how i can grow
all right so this is for anyone who's in
any company
the closer you can tie yourself to an
acquisition channel the more valuable
are the company because you're
you're driving revenue right and so what
i what i explained to him was i said
listen
you've gone through all my trainings you
know you know you know the different
ways of getting clients
pick a channel that we're not currently
using and
in your in your off time try and figure
that channel out
and we pay more for for leads or for
sales that come
that don't that that someone goes and
brings out brings in on their own
compared to stuff that comes in from our
marketing
right i was like so you're going to get
disproportionately paid for those uh
off the bat and then as soon as you
figure out that system i said
come to me and say hey alex i figure out
the system i figured this process is
getting us
more clients i want to build a team and
i think that i can show
five other guys how to do this and
generate revenue and i just would like a
piece of all of their
of their um of their sales and i would
say absolutely
and so if he does this he would be able
to two or three x's income
as a result of that right and so that is
a way of figuring out how to provide
more value now the next thing was
a debate i think this came up from the
family too was going off on your own
right now obviously as the owner of the
business
you would think that my incentive is to
keep it keep everyone
and over time my my incentive has
shifted my incentive is
i want to to be the best human i
possibly can be
and if that means that that this it's
time for that person to go
and spread their wings then that's fine
and i encourage them and i and i wish
them the absolute best and i mean that
genuinely
because i never want to be the person
who holds someone back from
accomplishing their dreams
that being said understanding risk is
important
so many many many many many people
many many many of my salespeople make
more than many entrepreneurs do
in fact it probably got the stats i
think the average small business owner
makes like 78 000
a year all right so if my salespeople
make 150 or 200 000
a year and if he does all this thing he
could make five times what the average
small business owner makes
five times five times and that's
income right that's what's important and
so
sometimes you can see the allure and
this is a classic employee mistake
is you look at all the revenue and you
say oh that must be the owners that must
be alex's
and every business owner who's watching
this is laughing to themselves because
they know that is so far from the truth
that is is hilarious
but but people still make that logical
fallacy
and so for perspective if you if you are
a 200 000
a year sales person you own in my mind a
million dollar business
because if you're running a 20 net
margin after everything that and the
thing is is it's not just profit in the
business but it's net free cash flows
the amount of money that you as an owner
can take out after reinvesting in the
business
right and so if you have a you if you're
a sales person
and you're making 2000 a year it's the
same as you owning a million dollar
business and so
many times and in this instance
depending on your skill set
you may not want to deal with hr and
finance and and figuring out fulfillment
and generating leads on your own all the
other aspects that come
with owning a business legal and all the
other crap right
and so i'm not saying don't be an
entrepreneur obviously i'm an
entrepreneur but i'm saying
understand adequately understand the
risk and i think that if i adequately
understand the risk and being very very
honest with everyone here
i don't know if i would have become an
entrepreneur i really don't know
because i'm pretty risk-averse believe
it or not and i think i've told you i
had a really good paying job before i uh
before i quit
and it was because i was so miserable
that i decided to do something else
but i did not have the typical
entrepreneur story of like
i was always bad at school and i knew i
had to do my like i didn't have that at
all i was good at school i got a good
job and i
i just i was miserable so i did
something else anyways
next point oh last one okay
so i'll give you another saying to work
off of track
don't slack all right
easy to remember and so one of the
easiest things that you can do
to increase your net worth is start by
tracking it
all right this is one of the easiest
things so right now every week i get a i
get an email
that has every single one of my assets
every single one of my bank accounts
all of my portfolios and it has one
number at the bottom and so i know
every week how i'm doing and whether i'm
going up and up now you might be like
well man isn't the market volatile sure
but i also have other investments too
etc but the point is especially
the earlier on you are you can you can
decrease that cycle now you could do
that every quarter i'm just i tend to be
obsessive about it i like looking at it
because i like making progress
if right now you are the sole provider
in your household or you're a solo
business owner or an entrepreneur or
even you know you have a
seven or eight figure business right but
you haven't like your your actual net
worth hasn't surpassed
you know a million five million tracking
every day
the cumulative amount of your bank
accounts is one of the single
greatest things that i ever did
ever like ever ever ever
and so it became this habit that first
thing in the morning i would open up my
my my chase app i would and the nice
thing is if you have one of the big
commercial banks
you can you can they give you dashboards
you can you can pull all your accounts
in together so if you have
you know two business accounts and then
you have a savings and checking personal
and then you maybe have like a portfolio
all of that stuff you can have in one
place so it's actually pretty cool but
anyways
i had an excel sheet that had all my
assets on them all my bank accounts all
my investments and everything and i
would take five minutes in the morning
and i would update it
and every single and i did it daily so i
saw every single day and i could just
scroll over time and watch my bottom
number
continue to go up and here's what's
magical about this
is that when you look at your bank
accounts every day you start to get a
pulse on the flow of money
you start to get a feeling for oh yeah
tuesdays is when this goes out oh yeah
on the first week of the month this is
when this goes out but then what happens
is all of a sudden you're like hey
i went down by 200 bucks let me examine
let me investigate
and you look in there and you're like
holy crap
i've been using the software for however
long cancel
right and so as soon as you start doing
this you'll start decreasing you plug
the holes you'll decrease the
uh the outflows of money in your life
because you're tracking and not slacking
so as long as you're not a slacker
become a tracker track your net worth
all right
and so for this individual the the
action plan that i made for him
so that he could create the wealth that
he wanted was this kind of recap for you
all right number one track don't slack
you have to track your net worth if you
wanted to improve
so how can you even track like how can
you prove something you don't even know
what it is
track track don't slack now your debt
should also be on there so if he's
paying down debt his net worth will go
up because right now
he's got 20 000 net so his net worth is
negative 20 000
compared to his cash right so boom track
don't slack next
pay off high interest credit cards or
high interest loan debt first
next dollar cost average all of the
money that you that you make in excess
of your
expenses into the s p mind you this is
not investment advice i'll probably post
a legal disclaimer
under the video do whatever the hell you
want investment has risks
there's no guaranteed returns life is
risky you know
no one comes out alive okay back to the
main point so
dollar cost averages to the s p and
actively decrease your expenses as much
as humanly possible
if you have a salary with variable
compensation on top of it
try and save off of living off your
salary and if that sounds crazy
cool don't be ordinary be extraordinary
do things different because the average
person
literally retires with nothing don't be
like that
you can be different and the thing is is
all of these things that we aspire for
which i made this other video about
right all these things we aspire for
private jets exotic cars penthouses
uh expensive clothing fancy restaurants
i can tell you firsthand
they're not what they're cracked up to
be i like i like bj's and chili's more
than i like
ruth chris i really like the cheap my
cheap jorts more than
any of the fancy pants that are out of
fancy pants um i can tell you that when
i lived in a 1200
a month apartment um in in in
albuquerque new mexico which is
a really nice place um i was happy as
could be it
my happiness is in no way changed having
the place that i have now
i regret the exotic car that i have and
private jets are wildly expensive and
you can
you can get anywhere you want on spirit
for way less
all right so decrease your expenses all
right
and um in terms of increasing the income
tie yourself to an acquisition channel
try and find a new way of acquiring
customers that the business that you're
currently in is not doing
do that and then build a team underneath
of you
that can do the thing that you just
learned how to do all right because then
you will be closer to what i call a
rainmaker and rainmakers are always paid
the most in every business
and understand that when you do that if
you ev
getting to 200 000 a year you own a
million dollar business it's the same
thing
right except you have way less risk uh
because
if you want a million dollar business
you can work your ass off two months in
a row and become poorer
whereas if you work your ass off for two
months in a row in a business you're
gonna get richer all right and that's
the difference between being an
entrepreneur
and employees that a lot of people don't
adequately monitor the risk all right
and finally understand the difference in
volatility
and risk overall something that goes up
and down a lot is not necessarily risky
it's just volatile and if you can
understand that words matter
and how you describe things matter and
understanding the definition of words
you can put better concepts and
frameworks around your thought process
and make better quality decisions so
anyways i hope you found this valuable
this was a great conversation i wish i
had recorded it uh but hopefully you got
the
the nuggets uh from that you can apply
to your own life in business
keeping awesome leave a comment and i'll
catch you guys next vid
bye